I'm the dark
knuckle dragging
right wing
Republican former governor of the state
of Texas
former Republican Texas governor and
Trump Administration Energy Secretary
Rick Perry was the most surprising
speaker at the 2023 psychedelic science
Conference held in Denver this June some
of you are out there going what in the
hell is that dude doing on this stage
organized by the multi-disciplinary
Association for psychedelic studies a
group that has been pushing for FDA
approval of MDMA assisted therapy since
the late 1980s the conference was
attended by a reported 13
000 people
Perry sat down with reason to explain
why he believes psychedelics should be
legal medicine for veterans and others
suffering from PTSD how to allow more
immigrants to come to America lawfully
and why if he were ever to take a
psychedelic drug it would be ibogaine a
notoriously powerful substance made from
the bark of an African tree
foreign
thanks for talking to reason well you
are speaking at a psychedelic conference
what is so important about psychedelics
that it brought you a Conservative
Republican to speak to people who as you
said you're opening remarks probably
were wondering why you were there yeah
when I got introduced to this
approximately five years ago it was
through a young man who worked with me
at the department of energy at that
point in my life I was the Secretary of
Energy and uh
he was seeing
some of his colleagues in the Special
Operations world this was a former Navy
SEAL
who interestingly today is a United
States congressman who is very vocal
very supportive of the use of
psychedelics for uh post-traumatic
stress and
he's the one that started
working with me on this
me getting comfortable that Rick Perry
and psychedelics in the same sentence
was even a even close to a reality
and his twin brother Marcus Luttrell who
is the author of Lone Survivor the book
and then the movie was made about his
experiences that brother lived with us
at the Governor's Mansion for two plus
years as we were
my wife and I were learning about
post-traumatic stress and how poor our
government was in dealing with this
frankly and we were trying to find
solutions to help heal this young man
and so all of that collectively Through
The Years brought me to a comfort level
that uh I'm a results-oriented guy you
know the process is the process I get it
but what's the results
and what I've seen over the last four
years in particular
studying this
talking to Myriad of uh young men in
this case there have been young women
that have gone to Mexico as well I've
just not had conversations with any of
those but these young men who have put
their lives on the line for us who have
been impacted uh
through all the different types of
trauma that come with being a Warfighter
that
this treatment this medicine works and
so
I've also you know educated myself about
the history of this and why psychedelics
got taken away from the research World
from the citizens at large from the
standpoint of being a a medicine that
could could work so uh it started to
make a lot of sense to me that you know
these are medicines that were taken away
for political purposes back in the early
70s
and that we need to reintegrate study
them do the appropriate things
but the potential here is stunningly
positive I mean when you just look and
I'll give you one peek at the uh Dr
Rachel yahuda
PhD who's working at the uh
VA in New York I think she has two
uh
studies behind them
phase three
that are showing just amazing results
treatment with MDMA two weeks treatment
with MDMA
treatment
so three treatments in a month period of
time
they have classic symptoms
anxiety depression
sleeplessness Suicidal Thoughts one or
all of those
75 percent of those individuals who are
treated
75 percent of those who are treated
have zero symptoms after six months I
mean that's stunning numbers so my point
is and and I got asked this early in my
engagement with this it's kind of like I
helped pass in the Texas legislature as
a former governor
uh I think was house bill 1802.
that allowed for clinical trials on
psilocybin in the state of Texas
veteran focused and we passed it as the
law in the state of Texas today a very
conservative
republican-dominated legislature
and State
and
we're seeing great results now yeah and
that uh Arena so
um having those results in hand
um why wouldn't we do this yeah do you
think this will sell well not simply to
Republicans but conservatives uh you
know the fact that when we're talking
about dealing with trauma with PTSD and
things like that psychedelics which you
know going back to somebody like Ronald
Reagan as governor of California was
like you know we got to stop hippies who
are taking LSD right well do you think
people in your political tribe will be
able to kind of grasp the message that
you're sending this is an education
process and the short answer is yes I do
because I'm not for legalization of
drugs I mean this is where I'm I tell
people I said listen we're going to go
we need to go a little more pedestrian
here government has fouled this up
substantially in the past let's not give
them a reason to mess this up again
let's go
thoughtfully at an appropriate Pace as
fast as we can
but the idea that we're going to stand
up and say you know what this is great
stuff let's just Legalize It everybody
is uh you know
go you know go find your happy place
that's not a good plan you're breaking
my heart I know I know Rick doblin and I
I mean I love Rick Dublin like a brother
yeah this is where we do disagree right
on strategy I don't think we disagree on
end result which is to get these
compounds uh into as many places as we
can with the right here here this is
pretty simple for me uh proper diagnosis
proper dosage proper uh guidance through
the uh the experience with the medicine
and then the proper follow-up follow-up
is incredibly important could you as a
limited government conservative can you
talk a little bit about why it was wrong
that the the government
you know at every level but especially
the federal level interpose itself
between you know Medical Care and
patients
good question my father-in-law was a
physician
and in 1970 there are about
he told his then 14 year old daughter as
she was uh
helping him in his Clinic
honey the first dollar we take from the
government is our first step towards
socialized medicine
and I would suggest to you he was
correct
you know I've spent pretty much uh
a lifetime in government
and um
government needs to be limited
it needs to be restrained at uh almost
every opportunity that you can
um and we haven't been very successful
with that in in our country
so uh
it's one of the reasons I still fear
that if we go too fast on this
before the public is fully educated and
fully supportive of the use of
psychedelics to to treat the the trauma
that's out there in our world
that we could end up
back potentially worse than we were in
the early 70s now I hope have you used
psychedelics no never uh what about weed
no anything like that no I'm I'm your
classic I mean 60s I grew up in a small
community where it wasn't available uh
and it wasn't there then I went to an
all-male military school in the in the
late 60s early 70s I went straight into
the United States Air Force where you
know the idea I mean we were tested for
drugs on a regular basis and it's kind
of like you know I would never put my
career in Jeopardy and went on about
life do you do you think this is the
type of issue you know we live in an
intensely polarized uh you know world
right now particularly between
Republicans and Democrats conservatives
and Liberals are progressives is this
the type of issue that people will find
common cause on yeah it's interesting
was just having this conversation
with some of the participants here today
at this juncture now and again I think
this is all about the education process
getting people comfortable with the
facts getting people comfortable with
the results but at the federal level
this is more supported by the
Republicans and here's one of the
reasons I think that
and
I'm I'm in a little bit of a silo
because I'm from Texas and I pay
attention to the Texas Congressional
Delegation and there is a substantial
number of farmer uh military uh special
ops Dan Crenshaw Morgan Latrell Wesley
hunt you know Jake Elsey was a F-18
pilot who deployed with the SEAL Teams
Tony Gonzalez a cyber expert I mean
we've got a lot of military August
Pfluger who is uh uh I think he was an
A-10 pilot
those individuals have seen this
firsthand they know the trauma that has
been inflicted on these individuals and
they've also
seen the results of the use of
psychedelics and treating this trauma so
I
I think there's
a bigger group of Republicans but
what I I try to tell people I said this
isn't partisan at all let's you know
let's let's take our our labels away on
this one this is about this is about
humankind this is about taking care of
individuals it's about saving lives it's
about giving people their lives back
and that's not a Democrat or Republican
issue but you know I'm I'm not Pollyanna
here I understand that you know politics
always sticks its ugly little head into
things so do you think uh after you know
psychedelic uh therapy psychedelic
assistant therapy work is shown to work
for veterans uh with PTSD other people
with trauma and things move towards
legalization or decriminalization would
you be comfortable doing psychedelics at
some point yeah you know I I tell folks
I said that's uh
so there's a
early stage study going on on ibogaine
at this particular point in time
it appears at this early juncture that
that
one
treatment of that medicine
can not just reset the brain but
literally some synolytic values
turning back the the clock if you will
anti-aging of the brain
um
increased executive functions and
I'm quite interested in that as a 73
year old uh you know healthy uh man that
uh you know so there's a naturally
occurring substance that properly dosed
properly diagnosed properly guided
through properly followed up with that
can make my executive
thought process better that can
literally turn back uh the clock so to
speak
and as a personal note I was concussed
substantial a number of times as a Young
Man growing up just I grew up on a ranch
grew up on a farm grew up playing
six-man football and there were there
were a number of times that I was
concussed and I'm talking about serious
concussions where you're out for over a
minute or two I mean literally laying
there so we know now that that long-term
cumulative
trauma on the brain
um maybe one of the reasons that um
I always been
chasing the sleep at night Moby Dick of
my life has been to get a night's sleep
you think that might have something to
do with it well certainly could what uh
can you just comment on what a world of
Wonders it must be like if 13 year old
you or 23 year old you is saying okay
not only you know I'm a you know a
popular lieutenant governor governor of
Texas and I'm going to be talking about
we need to get psychedelics out into the
medicine cabinet of America yeah I mean
literally five years ago
if you told me that my name in
psychedelics was going to be in the same
sentence uh I would have looked a bit a
scant at you do you uh this is a little
bit off topic you know one of the things
that I think Texas you know where I've
lived was actually great on was
immigration Texas is a state that takes
in people from all over the world you
know particularly the relationship with
Mexico and Texas is is incredible
uh it's a real sticking point for the
Contemporary Republican party there
isn't anybody there who is willing to
say you know what we need more
immigrants and we need more legal
immigration is that going to change and
is that something else
interesting idea if you'll recall I ran
for president in 2011. 2012. and as I
tell people if you also recall in August
of 2011 I literally went to the top of
the of the of the polls and I tell
people it was three of the most
exhilarating hours of my life that's
about how long I stayed up there but
I laid out a a plan for immigration
and I'll give you the quick
Cliff Notes version here because I still
think it makes a lot of sense
particularly with the last 10 years and
what's happened
you have everyone in this country go to
their
Embassy or to their consulate and you
register we take your biometric data so
we know who you are and we give you a
card that allows you to be legally in
this country you're a legal alien or you
know I'm not afraid of that terminology
that's not a negative you're a legal
alien you're here here's who I am I come
here didn't necessarily come here
legally but I'm here yeah
every year you go down swipe your card
and if you paid your taxes you kept your
nose clean you have stayed within the uh
the parameters of the laws of the state
you live in you're good to stay for
another year now if you want to become a
citizen of the United States there's the
line right over there you go get in the
line go through the process to become a
citizen but as long as you stay
working within the the laws of the state
you're good to stay here from now on
correct and
I got really criticized because people
said oh that's amnesty right well it
wasn't amnesty it was it was a way to
know who the people are and
we would have it during that period of
time
building the the wall I don't have a
problem with building a wall and because
we want to be able to allow people to
come in follow the process but if you
get sent back because you broke the laws
for whatever reason you lost your
your right to be in this country and you
get
exported so to speak you get deported
you're not just going to cross the
border and come back in so there's a
real punishment there and people are
going to
work hard to stay in the United States
work hard to be living in the to the
laws of our our states and our country
so
I don't know why we can't sit down and
have that kind of
logical conversation again about that
relatively simple way to register people
and to keep the workforce that we need
in in this state without
having
all of the illegal challenges and
problems whether it's the human
trafficking the sexual trafficking
that's going on the fentanyl problem
that we got
seemed like it would make a lot more
sense to me thank you very much Governor
Mike Perry thank you thank you brother
[Music]
foreign